[Music]
on today's show we talked to a father of
five
husband
who's just
worn
out
we talk about loneliness and what he can
do next and we also talk to a young
woman whose husband is a serial cheater
she doesn't know what to do next stay
tuned
[Music]
what up what up this is john with the dr
john dolone's show so glad you're with
us talking about mental health and
relationships in life and whatever else
and i'm just looking at myself in this
return monitor here
i need a haircut so bad
i look like it's 1975.
is it not like starting to just poof out
it's like i put my thumb in my mouth and
blew real hard i just went
and just shot out like a chia pet
today has got to be a haircut day
we should get a deal with super cuts
no
not a lot of love not a lot not a lot of
support faces in there
ah i've been going to the same barber
forever that's cool well hey nothing
enough about my my
incredible haircut here i'm so glad
you're with us if you want to be on the
show one eight four four six nine three
thirty two ninety one it's one eight
four four six nine three three two nine
one go to johndaloni.com
ask
make sure you scroll down go to john.com
scroll down join our newsletter we are
sending out all kinds of fun goodies and
shenanigans and exciting things and fun
and
i don't even talk about my haircuts and
those things so let's go right oh before
we go this first caller's from houston
this is kind of weird filming the show
because when it airs we will know the
outcome
of my beloved astros who have redeemed
themselves from their cheating episodes
you guys know i love redemption
are playing the atlanta braves and i
expect them to win in four to five games
the astros because they rule and the
braves drool so let's go to rick and i
guess i'm seven hey rick what's up
brother
hey can you hear me yeah i can dude h2o
hey all right so i'm just shouting out
houston here
go astros i don't i don't know if
they're gonna who knows
but hey man so what's up how can i help
all right uh 45 married five kids
happily married
one kid special needs and
he's awesome
so
work
very active with the kids coach
doctor appointments parent-teacher
conference
you know
definitely you know all in cook
you know
i feel like i'm very active i think my
wife would agree
that i'm a very hands-on
always get always helping okay
my problem is
and i want to say hold on i want to do
thank you because
you your show you taught me
what anxiety is
and how that can lead to depression yep
and so i was always thinking i was like
well i'm just a
down guy
but i was really experiencing a lot of
anxiety so i thank you for that you got
it brother thanks for listening and so i
was reading up i've been reading up on
that well anyway so
um and so i get down in the dumps
because or i get anxiety because i suck
at everything i do um
it seems like i suck when i help out the
kids it sucks when i coach their teams
i suck at work
um
i suck when i make dinner
i uh i mean
it seems like i when i drive the car my
wife's always
correcting me
and uh
i i'm just worn out and uh i i just get
like i can't think you know
i look to the future
and i don't get excited about anything
anymore yeah i'm just uh and i'm not
like physically worn out i'm like uh
mentally worn out
and uh and i guess i get in what really
gets me just throws me for a loop is
when like
i gotta go to like uh
you know
the latest test result on my my child's
you know cognitive disability and stuff
like that and i just hate those yeah and
i and i'm just like you know
because during you know life you know i
run we run
we play
we goof around we go to the store
we tell jokes
and uh
and i get real
angry i guess when someone puts
and i get it just kills me when someone
puts a score on a piece of paper that
tells me
or supposed to tell me like
what he can't do
or what his limitations are
and
and i i cuz and it takes me like about a
month and so what i started doing as i
started you know
and i get that it's my something's wrong
with me
and so i started writing i start writing
down my concerns and i start you know
charting them
so
like
diet and everything alcohol intake i try
to track like
is there you know what am i doing or not
doing that may
make me vulnerable to
getting down yeah
um
and so changing my diet changing
workouts and all that stuff
changing what i watch changing how much
i read
and stuff changing how much sleep i get
but really what it is it's just
it's
i just feel like
i'm always
i'm never good enough in anything i do
yeah and i my wife would say i do a lot
yeah who told you you're not good enough
well just the feedback i mean
as much as my wife asked me to do stuff
she's all you know once i do it she's
always telling me how i should have done
it
okay um once i you know i go to work
and i feel like i got to say yes to
stuff and i do and i just i get
overwhelmed and i just
i get
it's the product i put out i don't like
it but it's like
you i have to get it done and then my
kids you know they're always
you know i didn't do this right in the
game right i i should have done this or
i didn't want to go to the doctor you
didn't tell the doctor this or
i wanted this outfit and you didn't give
me a chance and it's just like oh god
you know it's just like
hey i tell you man
it's like
i know this is horrible it's like man
you know what
maybe one day i'm just gonna like
you know get cancer or something and i
want to worry about this anymore and so
that's it and so i need tips on like
how to
constructively you know
one i think i need to you know it's my
thinking or the way i look at the world
and i how do i
how do i hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on
number one
this is the bravest phone call i've
received in months
so
you can walk through today thinking that
you're gonna suck at everything you
didn't suck at this
okay and you've listened to this show
enough to know i don't lie to people
it's the bravest phone call i've
received in a long time
and what you need right now is not
a new diet
or a new program or a couple of tips
my guess is
you are real
real lonely and you have been for a long
long time
am i right or wrong
yeah i i move around a lot so i don't i
don't get a chance to have buddies so
here's what i hear
i hear a guy
who the world is lucky to have
because you understand duty and you
understand responsibility and you've
made it your life mission to serve those
around you
and you've done all of that at the
expense of you
and when you don't have
deep rooted relationships
when nobody's ever said you know what
my life is better because of you
i'm so glad
that i get to have rick as my son
nothing in the world makes me happier
than waking up knowing that rick is my
kid
when no one says i could have married
any yahoo
god i'm so glad i chose rick
when you don't have buddies saying
that's seriously what you're gonna wear
you look like an idiot but come anyway
you're paying you're paying
you run to the bathroom and so someone's
paid for all the beers at the table
when you live life untethered and this
isn't a knock on you this is the world
that you were shot out of
you can chase all of the quote unquote
right things to do down
and you get to that moment when you're
in your early 40s your late 30s and you
just say dude i'm exhausted i'm out
because you're unanchored
it's like sprinting in the pool you
don't go anywhere but you're just
running running running running
who told you as a kid
that rick sucks that's a message that
has been in your life for a long long
time
no i don't
i don't know
you know
you know what
who told me i mean
i don't know maybe life you know no
no somebody either told you that hey
dude you suck
or somebody never said anything
maybe in swimming i don't know
i was trying to be a good swimmer your
folks were great
they were they did the best they could
yeah you don't they don't they don't
need you to protect them
well they were awesome
i'm not i i get i don't wanna everyone
blames their parents nope
childhood we're not blaming it
all i'm doing is just trying to i want
you to see
that your moment in time right now
is a something that you can absolutely
heal from
and two
i don't want you to think it is just i
need to quit eating apples and start
eating oranges
that this is a thread that's
run through the tapestry of your
life and so let's do this don't have to
talk about your folks that's cool
but you and i both know that this threat
has been there for a minute
and you started the call by saying how
great your marriage is
it's not
and i've had seasons
where i've been in a bed with somebody
who i i know loves me
but i felt completely and totally on my
own
that's loneliness man
and you can roll your eyes and be like
bro dude it's not loneliness i just need
the right it's not i'm telling you
what's what's going on in your marriage
man
mean
i mean i look i
i desperately love and need my wife
but
i guess
you know she's also
works got kids and
is married and
probably stresses about you know
special needs and all that stuff but
um
and so
yeah i don't really
you know i i can't burden her with
you know
stuff that
she can't do anything about
brother
so i mean i don't want to bring her down
or something like you know or just
i want to bring her up listen man she
you're not going to bring her up by
making sure the trash is out
you're going to bring her up
by saying here is all of me
and when you protect her from herself
and you hide parts of yourself the parts
that are dying on the vine
the parts that are in
a black hole
she feels that you're not she's not
getting the full you and you know what
she does she defaults to the things that
she knows which is nitpicking and
complaining and nagging and reaching out
that is her broken attempt to reach
across that gap that she feels between
the two of you
and she doesn't have the words to say
i'm not okay either
and so it comes out in pokes and prods
and this is and what about that and are
you serious
and
you double down with the thing that you
know which you've been told since you
were zero which is
you're not a you're not a human being
you're a human doing
go do better
and at this point your body's saying
dude we're i'm out i can't keep doing
this
and what
i believe with all of my heart is that
y'all ran a lot you're running a life
with no margin
none and i'm not talking about financial
margin even though that may be the case
you may be stressed financially it may
be
time margin five kids is a lot in a
house especially with two working adults
that's just a lot it's a chaotic season
and then somebody throws a grenade in
the middle of your living room
which is a special needs kid which takes
extra responsibilities which everyone's
got some stupid opinion on
everyone's going to tell you what
happened why and what you need to be
doing you should be doing that you
should be doing that
and then there's no margin there's
nowhere left to go there's no relational
cushion to fall onto
and so you both try to solve this
problem in the ways that you've tried to
solve every problem throughout your
whole life
and what i'm trying to ask you to do is
this
that's not working
to try something new
and you are not a burden rick
your hurt is not a burden your
exhaustion is not a burden
it's a gift
and that's what she signed up for and
that's what you signed up for and by the
way she's burdened too
and
i'm with you man
if i
there was a season if i got one more
test or one more call on one of my kids
i was gonna lose my mind and i don't
talk about that stuff publicly
um and finally my wife and i said we
know this kid better than anybody
and we still
have support resources and all that but
i tell you what it's when we flip their
head just like you're talking about that
things did get get better and i don't
know what the disability is with your
kid that's a whole other phone call
but the key there was my wife and i were
together on that
and what
i can't recommend strongly enough dude
you sound like it like what do you do
for a living
oh engineering okay
this is gonna sound so cheesy and so
ridiculous and i'm a lifelong texan too
man so i'm i'm just speaking to the
choir here
you're a guy who solves problems
you're a guy who looks for
what is broken and you fix it and then
you move on
and what i'm telling you is this is not
a matter of something being broken
this is something different
this is something that needs healing
from the inside out and unfortunately
that healing doesn't start with
um lifting heavier weights
this healing starts with you grabbing
both of your wife's hands and taking her
out somewhere and saying i'm exhausted
and i haven't been honest with you for a
season and i don't know what to do
well what if she doesn't know what to do
then you know two people that don't know
what to do that's the guy who's trying
to solve a thing to fix it like this is
an engine
and it's not
then what you do is you both
say
you both smile and go
we've got a new adventure ahead of us
and what i will tell you is if you will
submit to that that's the word
vulnerability brother that's rolling
over and saying i could get hurt in this
but me not being honest
about how much i'm hurting
how much i'm drowning trying to keep
everybody around me happy
do you even like being an engineer have
you ever asked yourself that question
no
what do you want to do
i don't know i'm too beaten i mean i
i can't even think about that stuff
anymore
you know life happens it does
it it does
but you know what else happens rick
how come you've given up on rick
just
i don't i don't think i don't think
about that i just
i i don't
i don't want my kids in 20 years calling
into a radio show like you yours
complaining but their dad parents didn't
do this or their dad didn't do that
i mean
that's
they won't you know they're gonna call
in they're gonna call in and say i never
knew my dad
and i always knew that dad wasn't happy
and i've spent my life trying to figure
out what what it was about me that he
wasn't happy
okay
the greatest gift you can give your kids
is to be true to yourself and not in
some i'm going to quit my job and join
the theater and run away into a circus
that's what i'm talking about
the greatest gift you can give your kids
let's look at a quarterback dude the
greatest gift a quarterback can do is
sit out two games and heal his knee
if he keeps running around on the field
and saying dude i'm a quarterback i got
to be here
he plays not great
and then that knee gets worse the team
doesn't do as well and it's better for
everybody to stop for a second and get
well
and you've got to take your engineering
brain off and if you can't that's
totally fine
you got to sit down with somebody who
who doesn't have an engineering lens
who's got a healing lens
and i can hear it on you man
you know this is the right thing but you
also have 45 years of this is the way we
solve stuff
you grit your teeth and you suck it up
and you go get it done
yes
and i'm with you on that
and if you look at our country
this is year number five in a row
where we are dying younger
in the united states of america
from diseases of despair
addiction
suicide and organ disease failures like
lung disease and liver failure
we are playing a long tail suicide
in this grit your teeth and smash it and
pull yourself up and solve it is getting
us nowhere
got us a lot of really shiny toys
it's also got a generation of men just
like me and just like you and brother
i'm speaking in the choir here
i had a four-hour meeting with a doctor
this saturday this past saturday and it
was hard because he looked at my
genetics and he looked at my blood as
the most invasive blood test i've ever
been a part of i'm gonna do a special on
that in the new year on it
and he said if you continue to live like
this
it's gonna be a short ride
and he was looking at my genetics i
couldn't deny him but he could look at
my blood and say you're not okay
and i'm a guy who tells people what to
do for a living
so i'm speaking to the choir here
okay
all right i need you to hear me when i
say this
you rick
are worth
having your home be a safe place you
rick
are worth a good night's sleep you worth
rick or worth
getting home and your wife gives you
that side eye dude and you know it is
going to be on
you are worth getting home and going i
don't even know
what to say to that kid and your wife
going i don't either
and you're worth a nine-year-old rolling
their eyes at you and it doesn't ruin
your soul
because you don't suck at everything i
refuse to believe that
i think you're exhausted man and i think
you're absolutely just totally alone and
i want you to solve a relationship and
that's going to start with you and your
wife
and i'm going to be real honest with you
brother i think you need to call a
counselor
and say i don't know even though i'm
here i'm an engineer i just know that
the way i'm trying to solve this puzzle
hasn't been working
and that my friend is the greatest gift
you can give your incredible five kids
and when it comes to your special needs
kid you're exactly right don't let
anybody tell your kid he's less than
he's broken he's dumb
laugh take him with you enjoy your life
raise that kid and let him know he is
loved loved loved
and accept the services that are
necessary but don't let them dictate
your life
rick this is the bravest call i've had
and i'm grateful for you
i challenge i dare you to take your wife
out hold your hands look across the
table and say i'm exhausted and i'm
sorry i don't know what to do next
i dare you to go call a counselor in
houston and say i need some help
i dare you to take my friend ken
coleman's in fact we'll send it to you
for free
his
career his career assessment what do you
actually want to do man
and by the way my mom started going to
college she was four in her 40s
and became a professor in the back half
of her life dude you're halfway done man
you got halfway to go
our community our kids everybody needs
you man and you're worth it
step into it we'll be right back on the
dr john dillon show
[Music]
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john de loni show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor so i
partnered with betterhelp because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john delaney show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
delony
all right we are back
and take a breather off that last call
man
i cannot tell you the number of men i
talked to
buying closed doors on the phone via
email i come up here and visit me in
nashville
who are going through what rick's going
through
man
it's that exhaustion
it's that everybody in their life wants
more and more and more and by the way i
hear this from moms too
um
guys usually are quiet they just shut up
and they just zone out or they drink
five beers they stare in front of their
tv or they're 40 they still play video
games or whatever
but man everybody is just done
when you feel like you're just done i
want you to circle back
to two important things number one
relationships man you gotta have people
in your life and if you're married
you gotta reach across that table and
say i miss you
i love you
i don't know what to do next but i can't
keep doing it like this
and the second thing is you gotta ask
yourself what do i want i get one
precious
tiny little life
what i want
i want people to quit judging my kids
great
i want people to quit
asking me to do things at work that i
hate doing great
solve it
solve it
it's too late i can't it's not it's not
it's not it's not it's not
go to nursing school go to med school go
to
start a lawn business i don't care what
you do
why do you want
this is not a license to leave five kids
and go like i said to go join the circus
be like i always wanted to be a
screenwriter i'm moving to l.a don't do
that
what do you want
and so many people who have made partner
with their law firm and they hate it
or they're in their 14th year of being a
medical doctor and they hate it
and they're trapped by their big house
or i'm supposed to only drive these kind
of car what do you
want you get one shot
and for those who think man
i don't want to throw up a big mess
because my kids are gonna your kids are
already in it
they know mom and dad are disconnected
they know that mom and dad aren't happy
and what i'm telling you is your kids
try to solve it
and if kids have pictures of people
whining they're going to whine if people
have pictures of trying to solve things
through complaining or avoiding or just
gritting your teeth they're going to try
those things because all they know
man oh man oh man
you're worth more everybody listening
you're worth more
i was going to marry in tyler texas hey
mary what's going on
oh nothing much thank you for taking my
call you got it so what's going on how
can i help
okay so about two years ago i found out
that my husband was having an affair
with someone who lived in the same
neighborhood as us okay and
whenever we found out he came clean that
we went to counseling how did you find
out
i found out because the woman's husband
found out and let me know
whoa how's that phone call
intense and it wasn't even a phone call
it was
the word cheetah written out in my front
yard
that's how i found out
and
he ended up the husband ended up calling
me that night telling me everything
because she admitted everything to him
well
um
recently i have reason to think that
they're seeing each other again even
though my husband's claiming and that
they're not he's denying it every time i
bring it up
and at this point i just don't know what
to do what makes you think he's doing it
again
um because i have him on an app where i
can see where he goes and
i've seen that he was at her house
so
oh i'm laughing at
all of it
so you have him on like a digital leash
basically
exactly does he know this
yes
he's the one that admit that wanted to
do it because our counselor our marriage
counselor recommended it and he said
yeah i want to do it and he did it and
then so when you show him this app what
is he's like nah nah man no i was uh the
dog ate my phone and just ran over there
like what's he saying
he's saying that he was a glitch in the
app he don't trust the app
uh mary mary mary
he said other affairs hasn't he
yes this is the fourth affair that we
have since we've been married
oh my gosh
what are you doing
exactly why i'm calling you i don't know
you do
what is it about you that you don't
trust
there's a glitch in the app
what are you saying mary and then every
time it's like i feel disconnected and
he swears i'm gonna change it i wasn't
there i wasn't there and i'm not a
pleaser he's not
gonna change
he's not
he's not going to change
and i don't know why you
have so little value in mary but i want
you to know i've only talked to you like
for three minutes and i like you i think
you're pretty fun
and i think you're probably really smart
and i think you've been living with a
gaslighter and an absolute pathological
liar someone who has absolutely no
regard for your happiness or your heart
or your marriage vows or anything
related to you
that's what i think
and i think you are worth way
way more
than following your husband around on
the phone like he's a video game and
then having him explain there's a glitch
in the matrix whatever dude
you know that's nuts so what do you do
next
exactly we have three kids together
but that was like i know listen you
didn't do this
you didn't do this
this happened to you
and you've boxed yourself into a corner
where if i respond to this
i blow this thing up
am i right
correct because a lot of times i see
stuff and i just keep it to myself i
know
and i was just
i was just talking to myself before i
took this call
you're not keeping it to yourself
because those three little ones are
absorbing every second of this
you have girls or boys
i had two boys and one girl you want
them to grow up with this model of what
a man looks like
no not at all do you want them to ever
do this to another woman what's being
done to you
never do you want your daughter to
understand that this is what love looks
like
no do you want a man to ever treat her
like you're being treated
no never
there's a period at the end of that
sentence
and you know this mary
do you have any sort of family support
any sort of friend or community of
support
where you live
yes i have lots of family support okay
and i have a lot of family that's
telling me i need to just get out now
why aren't you but i'm
i'm so afraid for my kids
what are you afraid of
i don't want them to have to grow up in
two homes
they are in two homes inside the same
house it's making them crazy
they're already there
yeah you're right
it's already there
and it's so hard
yeah
so hard
and you've done everything you possibly
can for the last however many years
haven't you
yes
and he tells me every time he's gonna
change he's gonna make things better
he's gonna be more present
but it's hard to think how can you be
more present with us whenever you
have any second of thought about another
woman
it's it's deeper than that
it's deeper than that
i mean it's kind of about her but it's
not
you run you take care of everything you
take care of the food you take care of
home you take care of the kids
and you just go do whatever he wants to
with whoever he wants to
none of the rules apply to him man
you're right it says number four number
five you know what i mean like nothing's
ever stuck
something about the future
terrifies you and i think it's because
you don't think you're worth it
i think you put that in my head
possibly it's pr my guess is it's
probably before that maybe i'm wrong
somebody else put that in there
i think it's about the kids a little bit
just because it's the picture's
different right you don't want to be a
statistic you are going to be the one
are your parents divorced are they
together
together yeah so you've got a picture of
family
and you want that picture
and so you're grieving the fact that
that picture is gonna be different for
you than you had set out to
and i get that
but i think it's deeper than that i
think you're terrified
of
asking yourself what i want
you feel like a sucker for keep coming
back and keep coming back and now you've
trapped yourself into a loop what i want
to tell you is you're worth more than
this
you're worth being loved recklessly
somebody wakes up every day and just
thinks about you and they go to sleep
every night just thinking about you
and they wake up every day saying
how can i make mary's life incredible
and that frees you to think well how can
i make his life incredible
yeah
and somebody who's safe and somebody i
don't got to worry about every time i
sleep with my husband i might be
catching something from somebody else
and every time i go outside to get in my
car i'm worried about there being
another sign on my front yard from some
angry man
who my husband has gone into his home
it's just such an exhausting way to live
isn't it
it is
it's never you never have any peace no
and you know what you deserve
peace you know what your kids deserve
when's the last time you fully exhaled
your shoulders are up right now i can
feel them
yeah you're right they are can you drop
them for me
just take a deep breath and exhale
i just feel whenever i go through these
things
i just get disconnected from myself from
my kids
you do because for some reason somebody
told you that what mary feels is not
real
but what mary feels and what mary wants
isn't worth listening to
what mary feels what mary thinks what
mary says is kind of dumb
to the point that you're even wondering
huh maybe there's a glitch in the app
of my serial cheater husband
like you thought that for a minute
yeah and then when somebody like me says
it back to you you hear how crazy that
sounds
it's true it does and then you feel
crazy for feeling crazy
and so hear me say you're not crazy mary
and you tried real real hard and i'm so
sorry
and i will never tell somebody except in
extreme abuse situations that they got
to get out of a marriage i'm not don't
don't want you to hear me say that
but what i am telling you is you are
worth way more than the crap you're
dealing with now
and i think behavior is a language in
the language you have received over and
over is
you are second or third or fourth or
fifth place you aren't worth telling the
truth you're not worth being around to
you're not worth the thoughts you think
or the feelings you feel and neither are
my kids
yes
and
he does do this though whenever we
have these conversations he does like to
say
no but that's not really how you feel
this is how you feel
that's called gaslighting
when's the last time you talked to a
counselor
um
so i was going to a counselor for the
first affair right before i found out
about it because i was expecting
something but
i didn't know how to process it so i
started going to a counselor and i
didn't tell him and he was furious that
i was going and made me stop
so it was probably about two and a half
years ago
are you gonna stay are you gonna go
i think i need to go
you've been thinking that for a long
time are you gonna stay are you gonna go
i'm gonna go
when you say those words out loud and
your heart's broken and you weep
bitterly that doesn't mean it's the
wrong decision
that means your body may exhale for the
first time and release all that stuff
that's been holding for a long long time
and if you choose to stay i'll be here
okay
okay your family still loves you
but he's not going to change
there's no reason to change he has no
reason to change at all ever
he got the thought of he's got a freedom
that's what people are saying the
thought of saying just feels heavy of
course it does
because your body's under attack it's at
war
it's exhausting
it's tired of wondering am i going to
catch a disease am i going to get are
you going to find you dead in the front
porch
are my kids going to turn into this
right
that
the
when our feelings and our thoughts are
just compressed and compressed and
compressed and shoved and shoved and
shoved into a tiny little pocket in the
back of our soul
the hand motion there is just it
compressing in other words for compress
it just depresses everything
and you've been in fight or flight or
freeze for so long you don't even know
what it's like to breathe
to laugh from your guts
you don't know what it's like to guy
walk in and have your heart flutter
again because every time a guy walks
into your house your heart sinks
yeah
every time you get a text message you
don't think you think
and i'm tired of seeing him get text
messages and wondering who they are of
course
absolutely
when's the last time you said that
sentence out loud
don't even know exactly
you got a lot of things left unsaid over
the last few years mary and you need to
sit down with somebody and start saying
them out loud whether that's your friend
whether that's your family whether
that's a counselor
whether that's a lawyer
but i need you to hear me say
you are worth more than this those two
little kids are worth more than this
the decision's yours sister and we're
going to be with you every step of the
way
i'm going to holler back at me let me
know what you decide to do and how that
goes
and if you decide to go i want you to
make sure you've got people rallied
around you're going to be surprised
people show up with a moving van to this
one
my guess is you got friends and family
that are waiting waiting waiting waiting
waiting for you to make that call
they will be over there and clear that
house out in 30 minutes
or they'll take all his stuff and set it
in the neighbor's yard
where evidently he really really wants
to be
thank you so much for the call mary for
your bravery
[Music]
time for you to make a decision hon
and we'll be with you every step of the
way we'll be right back on the dr john
delaney show
the world has become more and more
chaotic and uncertain and loud and it
seems that everyone has anxiety i've
been there and so have you
it's why i wrote this small direct and
personal book called redefining anxiety
in this book i discuss what anxiety is
what it's not and how you can get back
on the road of being whole and well
listen
you are not broken and i'm living proof
that you can get your life back i wrote
this book so everyone could read it not
just science nerds like me and my
friends and i priced it at 10 bucks so
that everyone can afford it this little
book landed on the best seller list and
is now being purchased by the case and
given away in counseling offices
universities churches and homes across
the country i don't care if you're a
teenager or an executive or a 75 year
old grandmother this book is for
everyone so go to johndeloney.com and
get your copy of redefining anxiety
today
all right we are back i got an awesome
email from heidi
and she didn't tell me what town she's
from so i'm gonna make it up heidi is
from i don't know where's a fun town
i just thought of lancaster pennsylvania
that sounds great who are you thinking
where's that
steubenville steubenville
it's from that thing you do that's what
made me think of it oh that show yeah
another movie
the movie the film
the feature film the old tee hanks movie
that thing you do
steubenville
i got an awesome email from heidi in
steubenville ohio which um is a
stupidville
steubenville it might be pennsylvania
they're from erie pennsylvania james in
his off time is a geography teacher too
which is cool for all of us
and
that's where heidi's from it is ohio
kelly said it's ohio
you can always think professor kelly
coming in and letting us know what's
actually true
here's what heidi writes i'm subscribed
to your newsletter congratulations heidi
you were smarter than the average stupid
villiaite
and i read your article on emotional
intelligence i take back what i just
said which was insightful and helpful is
there anything you would add emphasize
or focus on when teaching young children
about the emotions they are feeling and
navigating them i have a four and a
two-year-old and we talk about our
feelings and emotions it's extremely
helpful but i'm curious to hear your
take on it and experience awesome
question heidi here's my thoughts
um you can go to john delaney.com and
get this article on emotional
intelligence and actually what it is and
it's just been so
nonsensified is that a word nonsense
just so much jargon and trash around it
on the internets and out in the books
and whatever
here's how i delineate this emotions are
just your body's response to stimuli
that's it
so
um you
walk into a room and suddenly your body
releases a bunch of chemicals saying
this room's not safe
your husband walks into the house and
you see him you can just tell he's
walking about three inches taller he
looks good your body surges
i like this
or your wife comes home and throws her
purse on the hook and you can see by how
she's carrying her
body posture
and your body floods your itself with
chemicals right it's just your body's
response to stimuli
hey you just crossed the finish line
or you just saw somebody fall
right it's your body's instant response
feelings are the labels we put on those
responses i'm excited i'm fired up i'm
so relieved i'm full of joy i'm pissed
off i'm
it's the labels we put it's it is these
i you know it's the it's the
um it's just the words we use to
describe things the way we feel
and so emotions by the way i use those
interchangeably because the delineation
is an academic enterprise it's an
academic exercise it's a waste of time
emotions are feelings just use them
interchangeably 99.9
of us can get by
our lives by just saying emotions are
feeling same thing who cares
so
emotions feelings are great for
communicating information they are
terrible operating instructions what do
i mean by that
you walk into a bar
you see somebody across the room and
they're attractive your body floods
itself with
she's attractive chemicals and then you
feel like i'm gonna go over there and
flirt with her
i'm gonna go over there and kiss her i'm
gonna go there and buy her a drink i'm
gonna go over there and because i feel
like
moving that way
if you're married
terrible
decision if that person doesn't want you
around terrible decision if it's late
and you need to get home terrible
decision
so the feelings are signals they are
terrible directors that's we need our
brains our frontal lobes to help us make
decisions
most of us go straight to driving down
the road somebody cuts us off we have an
emotional response which is our body
body floods itself with chemicals
then we get angry and we create a story
we feel angry we create a backstory
about why that guy cut us off and now
i'm gonna
put myself in more danger by
clinching my fist around the wheel
really tight and i'm gonna drive two
inches from their bumper and i'll show
them even though if we actually get in a
wreck it's just gonna rear-end them it's
gonna destroy my car and probably my
face
bad decisions
so
what i want adults to do and kids
is if you can just take
the gap is what i call it from when my
body responds to when i feel a thing and
action
or
saying something
if you can take that gap that's what
mindfulness training does that's what
meditation does it helps us control
those thoughts those feelings that shoot
into our mind and say
they did it because of this or i'm angry
or i'm in love or i'm no longer in love
or she's beautiful i'm going over there
even though i've got three kids and a
wife at home
if i can
pause in between and go
what's my body trying to tell me right
now
and is this a good idea is this a right
response so
emotions happen instantly feelings
happen instantly
fear that guy cut me off i feel angry
and then i pause and go
is anything i do next other than let the
wheel go say a quick prayer for that guy
i hope he's getting to the er okay
anything other than that is a choice to
be miserable
a choice to be
less happy a choice to put myself in
further risk either long-term
cardiovascular risk or short-term i'm
making a car wreck risk
or i'm gonna flip him off i'm gonna
drive like crazy so i get next to him
and flip him off and then maybe he's
gonna shoot me but i'll show him right
anything other
than that guy's in a hurry man i hope
he's okay hope his family's okay
and then
i'm just driving down the road now
my heart rate goes down that's that's
emotional intelligence i just got angry
at work
and i'm going to take a breath and not
respond
i just got an email and i'm not going to
read it until tomorrow
so when it comes to kids
yes yes yes yes the earlier we can teach
our kids
that they can a feel their feelings and
b
choose to do other things than what
their feelings are telling them
we are creating a generation of human
that is mature that is wise that doesn't
respond to stimuli
bam bam bam bam all day long
they can
go huh
that person is really angry with me i'm
gonna go this way
whoa that person wants to fight me i'm
just going to go on this side of of
school on this side of the hallway
because i'm not going to go to jail
even though i train in mixed martial
arts and my dad's had me in jiu jitsu
classes i was a little kid i'm not
i don't need to prove myself here i
prove myself at the gym i proved myself
a person of an honor and integrity at
home i'm not gonna fight him
i'm not gonna cuss that guy back
i'm not gonna lie back
i'm not going to
even though that person's beautiful and
i'd love to get to know him i'm married
i'm i think it's probably good if i go
home
that's what we're doing we're creating a
world of kids so how does that work in
real time in my house we're not creating
a world of kids we're creating a world
of people who think
and then act responsibly not responsibly
oh my gosh responsible not responsive
i thought i had something there it's not
there
um here's what that looks like with my
kids
when my
daughter comes in and she is
crying loudly
she is yelling angry about something
i will ask her
honey i see that you are upset why are
you choosing to yell right now
because i have to because so nope and
i'll stop and say hold on
your feelings are valid
thank you for sharing them with me i can
see that you're angry and you're upset
why are you choosing to yell at me
because i choose to not listen when
people yell at me
i choose to only talk when people are
expressing themselves in this way
i can see that you're angry you're
allowed to be angry
when you get angry i get angry on your
behalf or i choose to be angry on your
behalf
but i also treat people with dignity i
don't yell in their face i don't scream
i don't say bad words at them that's
what it looks like i don't hit back i
get to choose whether we hit and so
we're just teaching our kids
here's your emotion here's your feelings
and then you are in control of what
happens next
and this is something for two and a
four-year-old like heidi's man this is
something you gotta practice and
practice and practice and practice and
by the way the best practice is modeling
those four-year-olds those two-year-olds
are watching mom and dad
and so if they hear you talk it through
out loud this is a great gift for
yourself and for them if you talk it out
loud
wow
that guy cut me off wow we just got the
electric bill and it is double what i
thought it was going to be
my body feels really angry and really
scared that i thought that i budgeted
for a 250 electric bill but it's the
holiday season we had a bunch of people
over and ran the heater and it's
electric and it's 500
i feel scared about that i feel nervous
or i feel angry about that
and now
what i'm going to do next is go look at
the budget and see where we can find
other places or i'm going to have to
sit down with
my wife or my husband and make some
decisions about they get to see you
think it through out loud not just be oh
my gosh the electric company's ripping
me off at the
they get to see you act like an adult
awesome question heidi yes the more you
can teach your kids to name their
feelings and then have some space
between it before they act
the better our world's gonna be
all right as we wrap up today's show
here's another surprise song
from sarah
this is a good one
is this from uconn or sarah sarah that's
great
the song is called peggy lee
no is it by peggy lee
bye peggy lee
who is peggy lee
she's a singer from uh back in the uh
50s early 60s oh sarah's got the best
taste in music
except for the last time in the power
rangers song i still haven't recovered
from
songs by peggy lee and it's called
take a little time to smile and after
today's show we all need to do that
take a little time to smile
make a little thing worthwhile when the
moon comes up and the sun goes down take
a little time to smile
if you think you have a care you can
find them everywhere they'll vanish too
like the others do
if you take a little time to smile
smiles were meant to give away give a
hundred every day
and if you know the good they do won't
you please just give a few
try it for a while if you want to live
in style when the moon comes up and the
sun goes down
take a little time to smile sarah dude
i'm so glad she's in our gang we don't
deserve her she's so great
hey see you next time on the dr john
delaney show